who will the Iraqis support in the World
Cup match between the U.S and Iran
there's no single answer to that
question but there's no doubt their
country is involved in a game of
geopolitical football Iraq has been a
field of competition between the two
countries for decades and that
competition has often been a deadly one
the animosity began with the Islamic
revolution in 1979 although the two
sites eventually found the common enemy
in Saddam Hussein but when the longtime
Iraqi leader was toppled in 2003 tactics
changed after the collapse of Saddam
there was some indirect cooperation I
think between Iran and the U.S for a new
Iraq for new constitution for new
political system but iran-backed
militant groups who attacked U.S troops
in Iraq while pushing forward their
political allies to take key positions
in the Iraqi government this allowed
Iran to secure a leverage that it never
thought of during sadan's time the rules
were different with the rise of isil
with the two sides finding a common
enemy once again
the tensions remained there was still
the common interest in getting rid of
Isis after all was until
2019 that Isis was finally defeated uh
but there were also tensions between the
U.S and Iran over developments in Syria
and that played out in in terms of Iraq
as well the Iran nuclear deal signed in
2015 so things quiet down but not for
long it was a time for Americans to
understand
that these type of Iranian support for
Iraq for security stability of Iraq
could we would be really useful
[Music]
oh yeah Iran was shocked when the U.S
assassinated its top General qasim
suleimani at Baghdad International
Airport that was an unexpected scenario
in a crisis that was thought to be under
control since Trump exited the nuclear
deal in 2018.
it uh absolutely caused a big downturn
in in U.S and Iranian relations
particularly in Iraq
Iraq has been the arena where Iran and
the US have played out the rivalries
what many here just want Iraq to be able
to play its own game
Al Jazeera Baghdad